les murs balle de clémence boutinot est
ce que vous savez qu'ils savaient
clémente bottineau exactement alors
celle là vous avez vous lu ligéria quoi
j'arrive mai et rien mais pas et quand
j'ai vu elle est transparente cette miss
alors après vannes s'abaisse et couvrait
sa gueule tout le temps alors c'est
quand même fascinant c'est le problème
effectivement elle est enroulé les
civils tant s'en faut quand même nom
elle aurait pu faire le buzz et alors on
s'est posé la question effectivement il
ya la fameuse malédiction des ministres
c'est à dire que vous savez que pour
être miss france vous ne devez pas être
mariée ne vous ai droit d'être en couple
or toutes sont en couple avant et à la
fin de l'année sont célibataires
oui à tout à chaque fois quoi son poteau
mais je pense et il va faire elles ont
changé ne met pas en danger mais d'abord
est ce qu'elle est ce que michel est ce
qu'on sait si elle est en couple l'avait
avec kiel et on coupe à ce que l'avocat
ce bien oui pour coupe c'est son père en
fait qu'ils allaient chez land où aller
en coupe ça sent la chesnaie voilà elle
n'était pas forcément d'accord elle
voulait rester un petit peu discrète sas
et puis voilà le père a lâché au détour
d'une phrase dans une interview ben oui
voilà ma fille est en couple elle est
très heureuse de la presse people on
s'intéresse un petit peu elle ou pas du
tout je pense qu'elle est un peu
transparente quand même pas des masses
elle est bien faite elle a juste le
malheur de passer après une miss qui a
été très très populaire et qui avait
surtout été ouais y'a grande gueule quoi
alors je suis pas d'accord pardon je
suis allé vraiment transparente
en fait les missels ont tous cédé et des
découpes buzz chaque année elles ont
toutes été en un an mais ça parce que
l'autre à l'été dans le besq à des
rencontres demande vraiment quelqu'un
que je lui ai dit voilà aujourd'hui
quelqu'un qui a été miss frère
là on parle par rapport au fait que vous
trouvez qu'elle soit transparente moi je
me soucie en france c'est quand une miss
et de couleurs bien il ya toujours un
problème on l'a vu avec alicia eliès
aussi il ya toujours nez c'est à dire on
l'a elles font moins de couverture elles
font moins de deux motorisations etc
c'est quelque chose qu'on remarque luc
tu confirmes ça c'est une mise en
couleur en la mémoire couverture soit
net confirme pas parce que les quelques
rues et moi non mais c'est vrai que ça
peut aller oui alicia liste est vrai
qu'elle avait passé grand chose non plus
mais bon sonia rolland est quand même un
contact entre aime dire qu'on est en
train de dire que finalement la presse
s'achève en juin cantine a touché femme
de couleur vert fait pour le dit que les
femmes de couleur font pas vendre après
c'est horrible à dire baiser comme
tisséo arriverai pas alors et aînés a
trouvé par ailleurs l été on m'appelle
de couv de télé star cette semaine et
avec moi je l'avais juste l'année sur ma
table basse ouais quand on voit les gens
exagèrent et chez moi il s'est laissé
qui quémandent bottines aux avec
personne connaît son nom furedi quelques
pages de télé star avant de t'endormir
de terres cultivées en couple oui
j'étais en couple et à la fin c'est avec
la même personne
non et non riche vous démarrez avec
quelqu'un d'inconnu mec du coin du
tracteur aux footballeurs on compte
forcément d'autres personnes
après eux c'est comme dans la vie de
tous les jours les ondrais jamais avec
notre premier amour donc là en plus donc
toi tu es là avec la question c'était
l'amour est il incompatible que cette
assiette a répondu oui en fait je me
souviens que geneviève de fontenay nous
disait vous pouvez avoir un petit ami
mais il faut être très discrète à ce
sujet vous êtes la fiancée de tous les
français
d'accord d'accord la glisse sylvie
tellier quand c'est lui qui dit les miss
ont peut-être plus de tentations on les
amène dans des trucs fantastiques elle
croise beaucoup plus de jeunes hommes
que le laurentien que tu es un vrai jeu
lors du début qu'elles ont choisi la
notoriété mais pas leur entourage
donc si vous télé en train de dire qu'en
fait si tu appelles hummer forcément tu
trompes ton copain c'est un petit peu ce
qu'elle entraîne c'est un témoignage un
mot de toi tu dis non pourquoi c'est ben
non c'est pas incompatible parce que
c'est pas comme si elle perdait la mort
l on retrouve un autre
ouais nous on est très content
d'ailleurs à chaque fois il ya une
nouvelle histoire n'était jamais sorti
en boîte de nuit
je l'avais paris et/ou boîte cet hôtel a
plus provincial qui arrivait
startech procès du coin qui est un pas
de hold-up de la gare quand tu l'écoutés
des boîtes parisiennes du champagne mais
vous si vous étiez mister france veut
dire entre prière de vous lire ce serait
un ball-trap ans c'est une année où on
peut sortir avec qui on veut franchement
on fait est là bas alors alors alors
alors alors au bout du truc mais je n'ai
pas beaucoup de cette année tu t'es book
au musée la musique c'est sûr mais je
sais que s'il y avait quelqu'un qui me
plaisait je sais très bien mais comment
tu peux t'amuser cette année là parce
que tu sais que tout le temps après avec
est derrière toi donc tout va en boîte
de nuit les terres du fiso d'une soif
des peines lendemain tout le monde le
sait est énorme un trait pourquoi mais
il faut il faudrait qu'il reste quelques
jours ensemble le temps que ça nous
reviennent aux oreilles qu'on ait le
temps de faire des photos mais si c'est
juste ça veut dire quoi ah oui mais pas
la photo mais tu l'est plus tout mais si
tu laisses fait tout le temps oui mais
non bernard peut-être gentil mais on va
faire toutes les foires au boudin de
paris non plus on va pas dire non je
parle des foires